Hanyu wonderful to have you with our
fireside chat welcome welcome
let me trigger you with the following
suggestion is the Women's World Chess
Championship cycle in a crisis who you
fund the highest-rated woman since
Judith Paul Garr has withdrawn herself
I think it's been in a crisis but now
with the new feed air under mr. dois
quit it things are really really looking
up I mean we got this new free day in
October and there have been so many
reforms already and policy changes and I
think one of the big things that they've
spoken about very positively is women's
dress they agree that the way to to to
improve that and put it forward is with
elite events okay and to have a more
coherent Women's World Championship
cycle that has been a big change because
we know what the championship cycles
been like and this was one of the
reasons why you Fon did not want to be a
part of it anymore basically they had to
defend our championship in her case
twice and twice given year that's
correct
and now we're gonna see a new format so
the idea is to transition to the men's
format with a candidates tournament
right for the women and we will produce
a challenge which will be a challenger
but also in a way because we're gonna
have the women's knockout tournament
which is right now the Women's World
Championship right just a not just a
knockout World Cup a band right so the
winner of that will play the winner of
the candidates tournament to determine
the women's why champion show it's a
it'll be a lot more clear and the idea
is that you you know you qualify and you
play a match just like you do in the
men's cycle and you don't have to world
championships in any given year and yeah
this was one of the reasons why you find
it not want to play in the women's
whatever we're not gonna have that
problem anymore
that's right so I think it's not
actually in a crisis anymore yes well
it's one of those things where what you
just talked about and the election as
you said at the Olympiad in October we
have this new feed a leadership and all
of these rules changes yes well they're
going to be enacted
and we're it's going to make or improve
the woman's cycle greatly but then the
proof is in the pudding will who be fun
join the new cycle as we know she's now
at Oxford
yes suing her degree then yes I mean
that's to be seen but also what we what
we need to see is if it actually happens
these are things that are being spoken
about and they're on paper but how it
comes out we're gonna find out the new
fetus still needs time to put all these
things into action but I think things
are really looking up and you know you
speak to all these top players like Jim
and John and Katrina lejano
the musii Chuck sisters they're all very
excited about this format and rightfully
so and it might seem like it just
affects the very top players and the
very elite but I think that's not true I
think this is the butterfly effect is so
much more here because when you have a
coherent women world championship cycle
they've also increased the prize fund
from 200,000 to 500,000 championship
that's a big it's record-breaking and
when people see that and when they see
that you know all these things are being
done and the elite level chests for
women and and the fact that they can
actually make a living out of it you get
a outreaches massive at grassroot level
as well because you've got younger
players seeking up chess you've got
girls coming up and realizing that this
is a real career and they've got
something to aspire to
right instead of the whole messiness
that was you know I mean where is it
gonna be held are there any bits for the
women world championship we've had all
of that exactly right
but it looks like it's all going to be
very different from now on injury you're
coming from India Tanya and it just
seems to me that for the better part of
20 years yeah it's like the woman's
world champion has come from Asia yes
going on is that the water what's
happening uh yeah we do have great water
but beside but you know I mean I'm not
sure if it's really 20 years or so I
think it's more recently as
Russia has been very dominant in women's
chess as well it was Alexander Costa
Nick and yes well historically the
Soviet Union and Georgia and Russia has
had the greatest chess powers in female
chess
yes but then came I think things are
just really evolving a lot in Asia now
and there's this huge boom in women
chess and why that's happening is
because we've got so many tournaments
now that are taking place in India in
China in in Iran which are promoting
women's sports and how they're promoting
it is in a big way by bringing in money
into it unless unless people can feel
that you know this is a viable career
option and that this is something that
girls can aspire to be you know to get
into chess and to have a good life in it
I mean why would they put that kind of
energy from the start but that's all
changing now says Russia historically
has been so strong in trust because
they've had this huge chess culture
exactly it wasn't so the case in most
Asian countries but I think things are
really evolving because you know the the
government the Federation's are very
actively supporting women chess
there's also this this really I mean I
find it at least quite interesting you
know we hear a lot about people talking
negatively about about women chess and
can women play chess and you know you
always hear about these snide remarks
about playing like a girl and stuff like
that but actually my experience has been
very different my experience has been I
feel that if you were playing at a good
level and you know if you have talent
and you you've worked hard in the game
and you've achieved a certain level if
you can let your sport do the talking
for you I actually see a lot of respect
for women players all over the world and
you know the opportunity to train with
train with boys from a very young age
chess is such a beautiful sport like
that because because there is no
physical boundaries right so you can
actually work together and grow together
in the sport and I think I think for
that chess is a great tool to start at a
very young age and we see that in India
and we see that in
like China where there's so many
tournaments being held that we don't
even know where they're playing and how
right from like 2100 there suddenly 2500
the next time you see them because
they're all playing amongst each other
right you know you see when when you've
got an icon like like ji wen Jian in
your country or you know you've got
humpy in India you everywhere in the
world as this you kind of need that
inspirational figure for for the pioneer
is blazing new trails absolutely you've
got Cyrus audit now in Iran yes yeah so
I think when you when you've got these
figures we're breaking the norm and you
kind of see them and you know you see
also I feel the one big thing that works
for girls is that I'm maybe for boys as
well that it's there's this whole appeal
that just has and people are realizing
more and more that being cool and being
a chess player are not mutually
exclusive you know you can be both
together because because you've seen
these amazing when they're being proof
of that kind of work that you're doing
here and every time that I've been here
it's it's amazing to see how how many
people are involved and the way you're
changing chess here is well and the
image of chess because that's so
important because your message is only
really as powerful as the amount of
people in the lives it touches and if
they can see that if girls can see that
you know you don't have it chess is not
that image of being a nerd or being just
geeky or or not having a good fun life
but chess can be fun just can be cool
and then you've got this entire
generation of chess players taking up
the spot and then you make the women
world championship a cool cycle with
life with lots of money in it I'm very
appealing to everybody it appeals to
everyone let me share an irony I thought
that was kind of cool was in London for
the world championship match the
commentators were two ladies yes Judah
Anna and in the Women's World
Championship which was taking place in
Russia right at the time there was five
commentators and they were all men
an amazing idea right yeah it was very
entertaining to watch but I think in
general it's the whole the whole
scenario for women chess is changing and
then you've got tournaments like Karen's
Cup that you're organizing here I mean
it's always going to be the first of its
kind because I think this trend is
really going to pick up in a big big way
where women elite advanced oh we're
gonna see them coming up everywhere and
I think this is going to set the bar for
it exactly well I'm hoping that in the
future a tournament like the Karen's cut
will kind of be a candidate we'll see I
mean you've got the strongest players
playing here so it does feel like that